the Latino population is the largest
ethnic group in this country and they're
also growing very fast by the middle of
the century the Latino population is
expected to hit nearly 30% of America's
population I should probably learn
Spanish pretty soon to talk about
Latinos in America we went to Los
Angeles because there's some of
America's oldest and biggest Latino
neighborhoods are in Los Angeles so he
went to two of the Latino strongholds in
that city East LA and Boyle Heights by
2044 Latinos and all the other minority
groups will make up the majority of
America this next step sounds like
something that an athlete says that
doesn't make any sense but it's actually
true
the number of people who speak Spanish
at home in the US has jumped by more
than a hundred and twenty percent since
1990 that's nearly 40 million people
people I met they don't necessarily want
to assimilate they just want to be part
of assimilation generally is thought of
as the ideas that when one group joins
another group that they should learn the
ways of the dominant group so they can
blend in and become a part of the whole
but that's a very old-school idea of
immigration like just because you move
to America want to become an American
maybe doesn't mean you want to have to
make tuna noodle casserole